now turning to the economy in new signs
it's rebounding retail sales surged last
month in the largest increase since
march but many businesses are struggling
to meet demand and find workers meg
oliver visited one new jersey business
that's turning to high school students
to fill the gaps meg good morning
nate good morning here at montclair
bread company the manager noticed hiring
became more difficult after this summer
they're usually inundated with
applications after they post a job but
after their most recent listing they
received nothing
we get a little bit here and there but
we just really aren't getting the
responses we used to get
jessica woodward runs montclair bread
company she doesn't usually hire
seasonal workers but this year she's
relying on them to stay open it's going
to be a little crazy next week
especially for thanksgiving that's our
biggest one to get through but
i mean we'll get through it
she's working extra hours to get by and
turning to high schoolers could you stay
open on the weekends without your high
school employees probably not forever
or not always we can handle it in the
short term but it's just like all our
other staff would get burned out it's
not just mom and pop shops that need
more employees big retail chains are
expected to hire around 600 000 seasonal
workers to keep up with the growing
demand according to the national retail
federation amazon is hiring 150 000 new
employees kohl's needs about 90 thousand
and ups needs to hire more than 100 000
workers we have a new process apply and
if you have a clean
work record you can get a job offer in
30 minutes or less why the 30 minute
process we want to give an opportunity
to people who want to work immediately
to get that position larger companies
are also offering more incentives to
attract new employees amazon walmart and
macy's are among many raising wages and
offering signing bonuses health care
benefits and even tuition reimbursement
but many small businesses can't compete
i think on some of the customers getting
frustrated with
service being slower in places like have
to understand that
that's the way things are going to be
right now
businesses like this bakery are facing a
perfect storm with increased demand
staff shortages and rising prices for
ingredients like flour and shortening
nate
meg thank you